- Hello, my name is Jorge Bañuelos.
I'm a second year PhD
student in Yale's Department
of Religious Studies
in the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences.
Likewise, I have the pleasure
of being this year's graduate coordinator
for Yale Center for the Study of Race,
Indigeneity, and Transnational Migration.
And matter of fact, the rhythm
center is what connected us.
Wadada Leo Smith is a fall 2022
Mellon Arts and Practitioner
Fellow with the center.
And I'm very pleased to introduce him.
I mean, we're sitting
here with a living legend.
(Jorge laughs)
I can't overstate.
We're here with a truly
prolific avant-garde musician
who I have the honor and
privilege of speaking with.
Smith is a composer,
multi-instrumentalist and an arranger.
Residencies, you've had
residencies at the new school,
in Georgetown, for example.
You were on the faculty
for Cal Arts, correct?
- Yes.
- Yeah, and you were there
for about 20 or so years?
- 22.
- Honorary doctorate,
and then also faculty emeritus as well.
- Yes.
- And then also started
your own record label.
I think, by my count, over
what, about 50 albums?
- I got over a hundred
last year.
- [Jorge] Woo.
So my count was off?
- Yeah.
- And then likewise,
finalists for the 2013
Pulitzer Prize in music.
Also 2016 recipient of
the Doris Duke Award.
Wow.
Man, so, let me just,
I guess I'll just start
by way of an anecdote.
So I first had the
privilege of meeting Wadada
earlier in the fall.
You gave a lecture at Timothy
Dwight College on campus.
Speaking beforehand on the lecture,
I was supposed to run the clicker.
I said, man, don't worry about it.
We'll just improvise, it's jazz.
He recoiled. (laughs)
Would you mind telling us in
a sense why the words jazz
and improvisation are not
words that are in your lexicon?
- Well, essentially, they
was not intended for music.
And those terms was actually forced upon
African American artistic community
as a term that defined what they did.
One of the traditions that humans practice
all over the world,
and it's rare to be denied
it is a naming process.
Humans named their
location, their siblings,
their notion of what they do in life.
All kinds of naming processes go on.
So when the people looked at the music
coming outta early New Orleans,
which is actually the
southern cradle of this music,
they tagged it as jazz and
that it had improvisation in it
and all that kind of a stuff.
Well, improvisation entered the lexicon
about 300 and something BC, you see?
And it was dealing with theater.
Had nothing to do with music, okay?
And the word jazz come
from a baseball term
where they try to explain
the kind of energy
used in the participation
of that ball game.
- [Jorge] Yeah, yeah.
- And so, why would
you call the music jazz
or why would you employ
the word improvisation
when they have no meaning
whatsoever to that music?
Secondly, if you look at the definition,
improvisation means virtually nothing.
It's a collection of words
that you can't even get a
clear meaning out of, you see?
To do something offhandedly
that don't mean nothing.
So I reject anything that's forced upon me
or anything that's forced upon the people
that I'm associated with.
And that's the clearest
way I can define it.
- Well, let me ask you
a follow up on that.
So I gave an introduction,
but it's always more special
when someone tells us
in their own words who they are.
So would you mind introducing yourself
and telling me who you are
and how you narrate yourself?
- Well, I'm a human being.
My existing on the planet
has something to do
with my character of making art
and making art in the present.
I'm a family person.
I love family because that's
the basic unit of humanity.
And I like thinking and
deep reflecting about stuff.
Prizes and ceremonies and things like that
are very important,
but they have very little practical use
other than the fact that
somebody gives you something
or they something, something, something.
But the whole point is,
is that I think of myself
as a creative person
who is constantly looking
and striving to discover,
not just who I am,
but to discover the
largest or larger picture
of what this human
experience can be, you see?
So that's how I would describe myself.
- Something along the lines of the blues
and the abstract truth.
- Well, it could be a
way of thinking about it,
but see, even the notion of the blues
actually distorts what one would be.
Because
blues is a cultural
notion about our society.
It's a psychological way
of presenting information
into the society, larger
part of the society.
When we think about blues,
we always think about
this notion of 12 bars
or somebody singing about something sad.
Well, none of that's true.
You see?
John Lee Hooker, for example,
he doesn't observe no 12
bar frame for the blues.
He plays as long as he would
on any one of those supposedly chords
that are associated with the blues.
And he changed whenever he wants to.
But even that's superficial
because that has no real true meaning.
That is that he doesn't
observe this formalized form
that people have gone accustomed to
that they identify with blues.
So what I'm trying to tell you
is that blues has several categories.
Like for example,
Robert Johnson.
Robert Johnson gives a exposition
on a piece that's called, I
forget the title of the piece,
but the lyrics go like this,
"When I die, you can bury my
old body beside the highway.
"So when the Greyhound bus come along,
"I can get up and take a ride."
Now, that seemed like a nice
kind of a collection of words,
but that's deep meaning in that.
It says the same thing that
any philosopher from Nietzsche
to Pythagoras to whoever.
It says the same thing about that life,
that one survives death.
Because if his old body that's
buried beside the highway.
can get up and take a
ride on the Greyhound bus,
which is a physical
characteristics of traveling,
it means that that life
or that consciousness of
that person survived death.
But he says it within the limits
of two and a half minutes.
Not in a book that has 500
pages or 1000 pages in it
that goes rambling on and
on and on and on and on.
It's one of the most succinct definitions
about this idea of
consciousness surpassing death.
So that's one quality.
John Lee Hooker has blues,
it's called "Tupelo Flood."
That's one we just got to talking about,
that's a philosophical blues.
And the other one, the "Tupelo Flood,"
he talks about is actually
event that happened.
So it's a historical blues.
And you can go on and
identify and identify
all the way down the line
all these characteristics
that are associated with
the blues, where in fact,
the person that's truly
receiving this information
would gleam those kinds of qualities
that I'm talking about about it.
And not the fact that it has 12 bars
or 32 bars or 19 bars or
one and a half bars long,
or that it has these old kind of sadness
or something, something,
something, something.
You see?
All that stuff is dust,
but the real humans is
supposed to look through dust.
You see, because the dust
settles after a while.
Gravity takes care of that.
- And there are a couple ideas.
There are a lot of ideas
in what you just said.
I think there's one of
them I do wanna hop onto
about the existential quality of it.
That, in a sense, because to
me, I'm a musician as well.
Part of, to me, with the appeal
of being someone who makes music,
but then also deeply
appreciates the art form
is the kind of immediate
arrest you can get out of it.
And what you're saying
about that blues line
that you mentioned that
there's kind of like
an immediate haptic quality to it.
Like it reaches out and kind
of grabs you or touches you.
Is that related to inspiration?
Like, how?
- That's a form of of
being, how can you say it?
Informed, it's more
like an informed notion
where you actually are able to capture
the information that's hidden in the line,
in a poetic line, you see?
And then secondly, that
kind of activity is called,
you know, you discover.
You're digging underneath
the lyrics to find the truth
of what's being spoken about, you see?
So yeah, you could say
that it does inspire you,
or one, to look deeper
each time for something,
but the notion of inspiration
that we normally talk about
and associated with art
has to do with this idea that
new information is received,
and it's received, if
you create a musician,
it's received in the present moment
while the activity of making
that art piece is happening.
So the ensemble is playing
and somebody who's in the
ensemble gets inspired,
and that inspiration is new information
that's put into the pool.
And that delivers something different
than something that's
formalized and just practiced
and delivered as what it is.
And I don't mean to say that
a piece that's all written
cannot be, cannot carry inspiration.
It can, okay?
Many artists, Duke Ellington
included have pieces
that are completely written out.
Okay?
And they also have come from inspiration
and have this triggering
quality when it's performed
to inspire or be a source of
inspiration for the performer.
Same thing could be said about a composer.
Like, let's say, let's use an old guy
like Bach or Beethoven.
Their music is all written out.
Okay?
But that music came from inspiration.
And it also, it's performing
can reach a level of creativity
where it also, to perform
it in that certain way,
they have to also receive
inspiration how to do it.
- Receive inspiration.
So like, not necessarily generate
or come up with your own,
but it seems like the inspiration
is coming from somewhere else.
- Yes, yes.
- Do you have a,
could you put words, in a sense,
to what inspiration is and
where it might come from?
And where does your inspiration come from?
- Well, all inspiration
come from the same place.
And it's unknown.
It's called the unknown or the unseen.
And
the idea of inspiration
means to be inspired
or to be input, something is input.
And to describe it, it's like a stream
that flows through you
only for a few moments.
You can't even calculate
it in terms of seconds,
it's a few moments.
It flows through you.
And once it passes through you,
it leaves it's imprint there.
And what's imprinted there
is just for that moment.
And if it's used in a
performance of any kind,
whether it be dancing, painting, writing,
thinking, or whatever,
it flows right through
and it comes out for that moment.
You see?
But that moment is like a spark
in a world that's completely dark.
That spark lasts forever
because what was created from it
is gonna be part of the
human dimension forever.
Both in terms of
actuality as a work of art
or as a memory.
Those things are gonna
constantly be reincarnated
or reinvented through the population
of those that experience it.
So the seed is this big from the moment
of actually expression,
it gets larger and larger and larger.
And if somebody writes about it,
that's another source
where it is actually being
spreaded out, you see?
So it actually has
something that it gives,
both in a physical sense
and also a mental sense
where it actually continuously to live.
And I may remind you that
nothing that's in creation
is here and did not just
now come into creation.
It was always here.
And that which is here can never leave.
I'm paraphrasing basically
the law of thermodynamics.
You see?
It can never leave.
Spiritual texts state the
same thing in a different way,
but it never leaves, you see?
Yeah.
- So in a sense, it kind of sounds like
there's an absolute or eternal,
and then a contraction of that
into the world that we live in.
And then if we orient ourselves,
if we practice for it,
we might be lucky enough
to become a medium
for it to continue and move forward.
- Yeah, yeah.
The practice of it is
a quite simple thing.
That is, one have to
be desired and in need
and in the search of it.
And then when it does happen,
one needs to be capable
of using it, you see?
Everybody's inspired.
Most people don't know
what inspiration mean.
They don't know what it feels
like inside of themselves.
Mostly people who perform artistic works
recognize it more than ordinary people.
And that's because they
are constantly searching
and striving to discover something.
You see?
Ordinary people have these
same kinds of inspiration.
It comes into them the same way,
but they don't pay attention to it often.
They call it like daydreaming of fantasy
or some vague idea or something.
And they don't act on it,
they just keep moving past it.
But it comes through everybody
because if a person is
being actually inspired
and you're standing close to them,
some of that wave hits you as well.
Okay?
Yeah.
- So in relation to, because
you're a multi-instrumentalist,
and I assume that you still
practice down to these days.
- Yeah, yeah, I still practice.
I won't say how much,
but I still a practice.
- Yeah, 'cause I'm also asking too,
'cause for myself, I'm a drummer.
I've noticed that practicing nowadays
has moved a lot towards technique
and also making sure that
when inspiration comes,
I'm actually kind of ready for the idea
to manifest in that moment.
In a sense, how do you practice?
How do you teach practicing,
and then how do you
personally approach it?
- Yeah, actually practicing
part little bit later,
but let me say this.
Let me talk about technique.
We've been taught that technique
is something that's taught to you.
That's not quite true.
Technique is the way
that you do something.
Every time you go out of your house
and unlock the door or
come in and lock the door,
that's a practical way that
you get into your doorway.
That's a technique.
That's how you do it.
Same thing with the way in
which you do your research.
You see?
Or how you take a walk.
All these things are ways
and means towards something.
And when we talk about artistic technique,
it's always implies that
it has been established
and endorsed by some kind of a teacher
or somebody or somebody something.
And what I'm trying to
say is that technique
is actually the way that you
do something, how you do it,
and the skills with you
are able to do it with.
You see?
So, how do you gain that technique?
You gain that technique
by allowing yourself
to be deeply aware of what you're doing
and to take note of it mentally
or otherwise of how one does it
or how it's done.
You see?
And that began to be part of your kit
of which you work through and work with.
Okay?
Practicing,
a lot of people practice from,
you know, how their teacher
taught them to practice.
Lot of people practice
from how you think about
practice should be.
I say find out how you learn
how to practice by practicing.
And the way to do that
is not to fix anything
about what it is, how you practice.
For drummers, there's a
different set of things
that you practice.
For wind instruments, there
are different set of things.
Same thing for strings and so on.
Okay?
For drumming,
everybody wants to be impressive.
So they practice stuff
that would make them
appear to be impressive.
That everybody can say, wow, that's that,
that's that's that.
No.
There are drummers out there
that play with what appears to be
no trained technique whatsoever.
And of course they make the
largest impact in the world.
There are drummers who
were extremely trained,
but are able to overpass their training
and actually do something
that's absolutely phenomenal.
That's a Tony Williams, for example.
The other early drum I
was thinking about was,
we call him Big Chief, I'm
trying to think of his name.
He played with Albert
Allen and those people.
Sunny Murray.
Sunny Murray plays the drums
like nobody you've ever
heard before, okay?
And his impact is tremendous.
It's tremendous.
Okay?
I mean, like the difference between him,
he's a new set of Baby Dodd as
Baby Dodd was in the twenties
to everybody else.
You see?
So that's the distinction.
So, what I'm telling you this
is that if one is in a school,
you gotta find a way to discover
that real part of what you're
doing and why you're there.
And if you're not in a school,
you still gotta find the real
part of what you're doing
and why you are there.
That is, why you are in creation.
And once you discover even a part of that,
you've come close to where you're at.
That means you come close
to realizing your own state.
You see?
And what is that own state?
That's a true state.
I mean, it's called getting
back to your original self.
You know?
Yeah.
- Reminds me of this
quote by Ralph Ellison,
the author of "Invisible Man."
One of my favorite quotes where he says,
"Good fiction is made up a reality,
"but reality is hard to come by."
(Jorge laughs)
- Well, it's true, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because it also sounds like too,
in the style of practice or technique,
you know, just performing,
getting the ideas out
that also it's training
consciousness in a sense too
that you become aware of technique,
you become aware of
some things that you do
that kind of seem as if
they're just floating
in the background.
So like, for example,
drummers, they tell you
practice with a metronome.
You're not getting it,
slow the metronome down.
Moving slower gives you
more of an opportunity
to kind of hear the fine grains
of where certain beats are laid out.
But it's also training
the mind, in a sense,
to be able to hear, to
perceive, to have better,
more accurate perception of sounds.
Also, in a sense, to be able to perceive
what is really real.
- Yeah, that's one way.
The other way is to just feel it.
(Jorge laughs)
Because a stroke, once you make a stroke,
it's already set up something.
And what comes after that,
something comes after that.
And the feeling tells you,
it nurtures you to stroke
again in a certain way.
And if it tells you to
stroke more than one time,
and all these things are faster than,
they're almost faster
than reasoning or logic.
So you're working from your
intuitive self, that stroking.
And that becomes the,
that's a far more powerful
key than a metronome
because just you gotta
remember, Baby Dodd,
they didn't have no metronomes, you know?
- [Jorge] They didn't.
- You see?
What they understood was is
that if you initiate something,
that's the beginning and
that beginning opens up
all kinds of other possibilities.
And that other possibility,
if he's drumming or she's drumming,
it's the notion of how it feels
that the next stroke comes in.
And like I say, this stuff
is faster than lightning.
You don't have to sit there
and tabulate it and add it up.
It's already, it has
gone 50,000 strokes away
from that adding up and
tabulation of it, you know?
So yeah, metronomes can
be a by source, you know,
but also what overrides the
metronome is your feeling.
Yeah.
- Because then going back to
the idea you were talking about
with some drummers or musicians in general
who don't necessarily adhere
to a school or it's style
who are not trying to have
that kind of discipline,
at least, to be disciplined by something
or someone beyond themselves,
but it's a matter of groove pocket.
Does it feel good?
Is it hitting how it should?
- Well, don't call it
groove, just call it feeling
because groove implies some
historical reference to a beat.
And it's not about a beat
because a beat is about the count.
And it's not about the count.
That's what I'm saying,
it's about feeling.
It's more about feeling.
I mean, a guy like a Max Roach,
they cannot throw out
those unusual accents
that's a 34th on the
end of a set of figures.
They can't throw it out if
they're trying to count.
It can only be done by feeling.
You see?
And then when people try to tabulate,
they would need a machine to tabulate it.
You see?
The reason why is because the count,
which is always about
metrics that's not in.
There are other kinds
of rhythms out there.
My music explores those as well.
But they're called proportional.
They're not based off of a metrical cycle.
Metric cycle has either
12 strokes in it divided
or four strokes in it divided,
or two strokes in it divided.
That's all metrics.
And there's a limit to it.
If you look at the Indian system
where they have have
this horizontal string
of numbers thrown out,
you add them all up,
and if they come out to even number,
then you divide it up evenly
and you can say that
it's 25000 four-fourths.
Okay?
Or if it's uneven, you can
say it's 5000 four-fourths,
2000 three-fourths, 1000 one-fourth.
You see?
But still all metric.
Proportion deals with long
and short relationship.
- And you get rid of the fixity too.
- Yeah, you get rid of
the fixed quality of it
is that it's either long
or is it either short.
And it alternates between those.
Long, long, long, short,
or short, long, short, short, short,
long, short, long, short, long.
That's not gonna come up.
You can't even count that
up in terms of these markers
I'm talking about metrically
because the impetus,
just like the idea of feeling,
it's been pulled away from the metrics.
And there there are only
two kinds of rhythm.
Those are metrical rhythms
and those which are
based off of proportion.
Yeah.
- Man, I don't know.
I'm gonna have to disagree with you.
I like the fixed beat,
but maybe that's just me.
- But liking is overrated.
You see?
Liking is based off of-
- I need some model.
- Liking is based off a lot of expectation
and stuff like that.
But you know, you can like stuff,
but when the lights go out, dislike it.
(Jorge laughs)
- Hey, so this is a good
segue to move into something
that I forgot to mention earlier,
which is you have your own language
for doing musical notation.
Would you speak a little bit about that?
- Yeah, it's called Ankh Ross Nation.
- [Jorge] Ankh Ross Nation.
- Ankh Ross Nation.
- [Jorge] So like, Ankh,
Ross, Nation.
- Nation, yes.
- [Jorge] Got you.
- And Ankh, of course,
is the Egyptian cross, which
means vital life force,
basically, because when you
look at the temple drawings,
they pointed towards the head,
they pointed towards the mouth and nose
because that's the breath,
they pointed towards
the neck and the chest,
and sometimes they pointed
over top of the head.
Okay?
So Ankh means vital life force.
And it's a cross that's like that.
Okay?
Ross come from the Amharic,
which is the ancient Egyptian language.
I mean, Ethiopian language.
It mainly come from these,
but we have it rendered in
Amharic, and Ross means head.
Which infers the father
because we talking about a family unit.
And Mars is the mother's son.
So if you look at Ankh Ross Nation,
it means the vital life
force, the mother and father.
Which is the total
gamut in which reproduction
and creativity is taking place through.
So it's not named after
some musical thing.
It's named after the actual
source of regeneration
that takes place between the
idea of mother and father.
You see?
So when you look at that,
it's a symbolic language.
And by symbolic meaning that
it has figures, or symbols,
it has color.
Everything that's connected
with it has to be referenced
or put in place by the person
that's making the
observation of his score.
And
it's a score that's also based off of
the notion of regeneration.
The velocity units, which deals with stuff
that has a lot of activity in it.
Has four different density levels,
that is levels of thickness and et cetera.
That's on the fast side.
On the slow side, it has four
levels of lessen of density.
It begins to, from one to four,
the density level begin to decrease.
And so there's, again,
this idea of the right
and left, long and short.
And then the rhythm units,
there are six sets of
those, actually seven,
but I only use six nowadays.
They also have this notion
of long short, long short,
long short, based off of six sets.
Okay?
The point I'm trying to
make is that the language
was discovered in 1967
on a Saturday morning.
And it's still growing in,
what is it, 2022?
You see?
Because as I was saying that
when you really get deep
into language, and
particularly symbolic language,
every object that we see around us,
inside or outside of building,
all of that is language.
All of it, all of it.
And all of it came from inspiration.
You see?
That camera wasn't
constructed by some person.
They wanted to construct something
because they had an idea.
No, they were inspired to
look for how to do that.
- So two more questions.
So the first one is, you've
lived a number of places,
but New Haven is home.
Is there something about
New Haven that charms you?
Like, is there something
special about New Haven
that really attracts you to it?
- Well, there is, but it'll
take me a long time to explain.
- Nah, just give a little bit.
- Nah, I'm gonna give you a little bit,
but I'm saying that there are
other things that attract me,
but the most important one is my family.
They live here in the New Haven area,
which, as we know, is a fairly large area.
Got Hamden and North Haven
and a thousand other Havens.
You know?
Essentially, it's a small town.
I like small towns.
That's about the core of it.
- Ah, good, good, good.
And then lastly, so I mean,
obviously very prolific, what's next?
- Everything.
(Jorge laughs)
- [Jorge] Anything more
specific than everything?
- Well, I'm about to, hopefully
by the middle of this,
by summertime, conclude a work
that has 26 compositions in it.
that I've been working
on for the last 50 years.
It's 10 hours and a half
of actual music time.
Needs to be played over four days.
That's one of four or
five different projects
I'm working on right now.
So, that's what I mean by everything.
- Hey, well, Wadada, again, one more time,
it's truly been a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
- Yes.
- Take care.
- Yep.
(soft music)